حسناً أولاً لنتحدث عن ذلك أه
التحقيق في مقتل
الصحفي في أه 13 أكتوبر اليني أه
التحقيق تم بواسطة
رويترز أه لأن أه هذا كان أه عصام
عبد الله الذي كان مصوراً لدى
رويترز الذي قُتل وكذلك جان
فرانس  الصحفي الذي كان لديه
صحفي جريح ومنظمة العفو الدولية
وهيومن رايتس ووتش وتوصلوا إلى
نتيجة مفادها أنهم عثروا على أجزاء من
قذيفة دبابة إسرائيلية أو أورين عيار 120 ملم حول
المنطقة التي كان هؤلاء الصحفيون
يصورون فيها يقولون إنها أطلقت من
مسافة قصيرة  على بعد أقل من 1 و 2 كم من
عبر الحدود من أه إسرائيل من قبل
طاقم دبابة إسرائيلية يقولون إن
الصحفيين جميعهم تم وضع علامة واضحة عليهم بعلامات
أه على دروعهم مكتوب عليها الصحافة
وعلى مركباتهم كذلك دعونا
نستمع إلى مقتطف مما قاله
مصورة من وكالة فرانس برس أصيبت بجروح خطيرة
في تلك الضربة ماذا
قالت أننا كنا سبعة صحفيين من
وكالات مختلفة رويترز
الجاز وكنا في منطقة مكشوفة
كلنا نرتدي خوذاتنا وستراتنا فقط
نقوم بعملنا في تغطية الاشتباكات
ونحن  كنا نحافظ على مسافة آمنة
من خط الجبهة، لذلك كنا
في أمان حقيقي وشعرنا بالأمان ولم يكن هناك
حماس من حولنا ولا حسبة من حولنا لم
يكن هناك أحد كنا مجرد مجموعة من
الصحفيين نقوم بعملنا وتعرضنا
للهجوم من قبل إسرائيل مرتين  ليس مرة واحدة
مما أدى إلى بتر ساقي
والآن يجب أن أبقى في المستشفى
لفترة طويلة حقًا حتى أتعافى
مرة أخرى الآن أفتقد صاحب عمل ai من
الصحافة لقد ذهبوا إلى أبعد من ذلك
قالوا إن الضربات كانت متعمدة و
استهدفت هؤلاء الصحفيين
متحدث باسم الحكومة الإسرائيلية
رد على التقرير أه قائلا
هذا اقتباس نحن لا نستهدف المدنيين
أن العملية تستهدف حماس أه
في هذه الأثناء قال متحدث باسم الجيش الإسرائيلي وقت هذه الضربة
أن مقتل  صحفي رويترز
كان أمرا مأساويا لكن لم يعلن
مسؤوليته عن الحادث قائلا
إنه قيد المراجعة أه هذه
الأشهر الأولى من هذه الحرب
تقول اللجنة المنظمة لحماية الصحفيين إنها
الأكثر دموية منذ أن
بدأت في جمع إحصائيات
الصحفيين الذين قتلوا أه أكثر من  قبل 30 عامًا،
قتل ما لا يقل عن 64 صحفيًا،
الغالبية العظمى منهم من الفلسطينيين،
ولكن كان من بينهم أيضًا صحفيون إسرائيليون
وبالطبع الصحفيون اللبنانيون
إيليني.